studies in the stats show that if you
give someone in a study an alternative
you even let them think about an
alternative they are less motivated for
the primary objective so the studies
that I talk about in the book are they
get people to sit down and they say this
is the goal and if you do this goal
you'll get a candy bar let's say then
they ask the people to do the task in a
second study they say sit down this is
the goal if you complete it you get a
candy bar but just think about another
place here on campus that you could get
a candy bar just the thought of where
else they could get a candy bar distorts
their motivation and reduces their
motivation towards the goal the evidence
is really clear when you have a plan B
only detracts from your motivation and
your commitment towards the plan a plan
B's are detrimental in the context of
motivation towards a plan A